you watch Spongebob and plankton keep
trying to find the recipe - as Krabby
Patties
that's the mumbo sauce man nobody don't
nobody know what's in it everybody loved
it though Washington DC is the seat of
power for the entire country decisions
that are made right here on Capitol Hill
reverberate around the world but the
culture of the city the way people talk
the way they dress the way they eat
remain fiercely regional mumbo sauce is
a prime example of it a sweet tangy
sauce is poured over chicken wings
french fries even fried rice the humble
mumbo may never show up on a DC tour
guide but it's the closest thing to a
secret handshake that you could ever
hope for from a true Washingtonian
that's what I'm here for you guys
southern sauces barbecue hot sauce we
got our own social mumbo so you can
probably compared to like a hand of like
Polynesian sauce mixture like a little
time you get a honey a little bit of
polish it's different everywhere
sometimes like red some places like
brown unless I have blood that's right
that's the rice slightly brownish orange
right there and a burnt orange move it's
a hot-button topic here everybody has
their own ingredients they're signalling
readers and you know they would never
tell you they would never tell you how
to amazing people who are new to the
city might not even know mumbo sauce is
I don't know mumbo sauce sir do you
neither I never heard of this man
chicken wings but I never have multiple
I do not know of em both - oh sorry
I've never even heard of it if somebody
ever told me they came to DC I say did
you have mumbo sauce and if they say no
I said you haven't been a DC if you want
to unlock the mysteries of mumbo you
have to experience it in its natural
environment the carryout aka Chinese
fast-food spot I'm heading to grande
China
meet DC radio icon DJ flex and black
boot lead singer of the band Mambo sauce
for my first taste of the city specialty
there are three different Mambo sauces
and the DMV there's the perfect one
which is compact but more elegant or
faster bang one that's the best one then
you have one that's like a barbecue
sauce looking and it's not the one you
got I don't know where they came up with
this like big one and that's also it's
just objective in a sense that everybody
has their own taste of what they think
mama sauce should be no one passed out
the ingredients to the recipe I want to
get into the cultural intersection that
we have right here this is a Chinese
restaurant yes we're talking about a
sauce that was started in the black
community so how did this happen we say
Mambo sauce the first thing that comes
to mind when any person in beefeaters
will up off of it okay I can tell you
it's a carry-on on almost every corner
Chinese carryout stay very smart they
know what we like and we buy products
out here they sell hoagies Cece is Momo
sauce and chicken wing everybody needs a
bomb
I don't see mama sauce anywhere on many
years paratha you just know that that's
what you want tell me how I would order
this okay the first thing we'll see is
how many wings do you want to become in
numbers there will be a four I'll take
four and then you either have it with
pressurized or fry wax and do you want
to know is sad or had one everything is
your choice oh now now me when I get on
the ridge my gamma cycles grow mess
that's why I'm a different right
look I'm not afraid of a little mess I
feel like I can dive all the way in I'm
not just going to do this I'm gonna do
[Music]
so them good definitely has to be piping
hot though yeah yeah yeah so welcome to
detail I might stay a while yeah so why
is it that mumbo sauce is so beloved by
some residents and totally foreign to
others musician educator all around
voice of reason my boy Koo Chi is going
to help me understand the DC state of
mind you don't think that when you come
see see for the first time you have to
have my office it's not a food that is
at the top of the list for introduction
into DC culture I got to know you first
are you here to really talk to me about
these things are you really interested
in BC are you just like every other
tourist that one go to the White House
one of the Capitol you want to walk them
all that's all you want to do that's it
okay let me show you that side of DC and
you can keep it moving because you're
not interested in the people are there
like two different DC's okay the DC that
I kind of think of which is the center
of the power structure and the place
where all these whole white men were
puppets here was my life over and decide
what I do with my body
people from here we refer to that is
Washington so those are Washingtonian DC
is the caution of the city is there a DC
chip on its shoulder it's not north
enough to be considered north if not
enough to be really considered southern
so we're like in the middle and
sometimes because we're on the East
Coast we the Middle East you see fit
that translates into being culturally in
limbo exactly we are talent immensely
talented city but what people don't
recognize that we like okay Oh for real
oh that's what you really think you get
that if you can make it in New York you
can make it anywhere I'm like you know
what if you could survive in DC and not
feel like you got a move you can make it
anywhere
once it was called chocolate city but
Washington DC has undergone such
gentrification some folks are now
calling it cappuccino city author and
community activists coming Lewis jr. has
felt the sting of that new nickname as
he sees neighbors become strangers on
his very own blocks he's made it his
life's work to ensure the things of his
past like mumbo sauce have a place in
the future I grew up in Northwest
Washington I grew up on a small street
called Hanover place when I grew up it
was the epicenter of the drug trade here
in DC so now we have diverse communities
and millennium niju five neighborhoods
there's no community and people don't
know each other keep it on the top keep
it on your children's name it's painful
it really is will my child experience
anything that I've experienced because
that culture every day is is dwindling
what do you think is lost like if you
could put it in a time capsule for your
daughter what would be in the time
capsule go-go music as I knew it black
people in her community free wings for
our mobile so that represents us that's
black Washington we only give ourselves
like and carry up you know coming up and
down you got places like Hamilton those
fans next door and in some ways it's
like oh right soon DC cost you so you
can kind of appreciate that but then you
like it's like almost like satire like
they are they very funny yeah by seeing
it in a sit-down restaurant with a white
tablecloth is it almost like cute you
can equate it to a lot of different
things you know for like even like
hearing rap music like on set like on a
target commercial something like yo
something about that just don't feel
right but at the same time I'm an
optimistic person like I think it's cool
in some ways but I just wish sometimes
like if I was from if I was a tourist
right I'm asking my waiter like what's
Mambo sauce can the waiter explain it to
me a lot of businesses and real estate
have been doing this game called black
Brandon right without name the buildings
the Ellington or they'll have pictures
of black people on the building for
noble
I people live in the building like that
kind of thing so I don't want mumbo
sauce to get kind of you know great them
today as it grows the people that made
it what is there being a race that's my
issue not marble sauce is growth Mambo
is gaining exposure thanks to a few
entrepreneurs who think that the sauce
deserves to be right next to sriracha on
grocery store shelves
it's a movement driven by DC lifers who
know and love it best but also feel like
it's time to put that DC stamp on the
world I'm an junior chef IDO kitchen
crate he has a mumbo sauce company that
he's doing that I'm helping him with you
know he got his mumbo sauce and I
co-signed you know saying so we gonna
try bring that to the world I had no
intention on putting in a bottle and
selling it I got married and we moved
out to the suburbs it was just something
that I could no longer get access to
anymore so I thought that wow what if
there are other people in the United
States who now has moved away from the
Washington DC area who love this
homegrown sauce and can no longer get
access Capital City mumbo sauce by far
the best one package it does up that's
the color test and what the taste is
amazing I'll take off the Californian
they love it and we're trying to
position ourselves to be the bridge that
we can all agree on
they kind of unites both sides the
people who were here the people who are
coming that this is something that we
can all rally around as our thing like I
wanted to be a worldwide thing that way
no matter where I go I can always get mo
sauce I want to know how long is it
going to take from almost all civilian
stores because I will buy six bottling
the sauce isn't the only way to keep the
culture alive
DJ Bream's traveling house party is a
testament to the power of gogo and
chicken wings smothered with sweet and
tangy sauce as mumble expands Breen's
and his crew are keepers of the flame
for a new generation
what if somebody just says hey it's just
like a sweeter ketchup oh that's so
disrespectful I can't I can't like that
wrong you want um mumbo sauce to be you
know in every restaurant around the
country absolutely I'm here cuz I love
mumbo sauce and I created a movement out
of that we have a party that is actually
seen chicken and Mambo sauce like what
are your thoughts on that and look I
like it we're gonna bring it up a level
for the summer I really took time to
think like you know what food can you
only get in the DMV and like I really it
was chicken and Mambo sauce and it's
like after that it was a go like let's
do it let's do it
it's always to kind of celebrate the DC
experience and also kind of like bring
it out to the world so everyone can
understand like DC's more than just
politics we bring the hottest DJs from
the city we bring the freshest chicken
and mumbo sauce sometimes you bring that
gogo element we bring a go-go band out
gogo is like the heartbeat of the city
and mumble of sauce is like the blood
that keeps it all flowing do you think
that DC doesn't get enough credit for
its influence sure what is it - - almost
anything that's why I'm going to shine a
light
honestly DC's been changing like it was
once the chocolate city and you know
we're trying to bring that chocolate
back it's kind of like Community
Development ela every city counting the
same and everybody bought three changes
but it's just up to the people that
really from this year recommend all
right and you know bring that culture
back let me show you this out of DC let
me show you this other side of DC let me
show you the people of DC let me show
you the culture theme it's not just the
food it's the community that's around
the food missing do you know it is get
me following mumbles oils on the side
when you taste it always back in here
your uncle asked you homeless but you
know the soul of the city will remain
you know go-go music and mumbo sauce
Oh mumbles dogs disappeared in they got
it the war zone is over the world is
over got to set it down it'll be crazy
[Music]